Smart投資教室上課了
大家好
我是基金小姐姐璇依
節目開始
我想先請大家思考一下
我們當然知道說
投資分兩條路
一種叫做資產增值
另外一種希望可以追求
被動收入
所以說
你喜不喜歡這種就是
不用一直盯盤
可是定期有叮咚叮咚
也就是 現金流進來的投資
像我身邊就有不少朋友
除了投資股票之外
也會配置一些債券
或是債券型的ETF
因為比起追求價差
資產增值
他們更在意的的是
被動收入
還有整個投資組合的
穩定度
可是問題來了
想要用債券幫自己創造
被動收入該怎麼挑
今天我特別請到的是
展新投顧的創辦人
黃大展
大展哥
來跟我們聊聊這個話題
先跟大家打聲招呼
璇依好
各位Smart投資教室的朋友
大家好
我是大展
祝福看到這集朋友
都可以鴻圖大展
大展鴻圖
有梗有梗有梗
非常謝謝大展哥
那其實大展哥
比較少來Smart投資教室
所以我先幫大家
來介紹一下
其實大展哥
他的這個
在金融圈的資歷
非常非常的豐富
他過去有待過了
野村投信
還有博瑞投信
累積了很多投資的心得之後
就成立了展新投顧
然後同時
大家可能也
看過他的文章
他在這個網路上的筆名
叫做小老闆
所以他的粉專叫
《小老闆的二三事》
所以大家看完之後
如果覺得意猶未盡的話
都可以到
《小老闆的二三事》
這個粉專來跟他討論
也可以追蹤起來
歡迎大家來找我
大展哥
我剛剛一開始
就破題了
就是有些人會想要透過
配置債券
或是債券ETF
希望可以創造被動收入
但是
因為聊債券真的是
太不性感了
加上老實說可能會喚醒
一些人心中的傷痛
因為還有一群債蛙
也就是過去2023年
2024年買美債ETF的人
可能到現在
都還沒有解套
所以他們對於債券投資
光這四個字就會覺得
很有陰影
今天很需要你
給大家明燈
讓大家重新認識
債券投資的另一種選擇
我想的確是這樣子
那今天我們錄影時間
早上的這個FED
做了一個
2023年以來
第一次升息的一個動作
那我想過去幾年
投資美債的朋友們
一定是想說
美債進入一個降息循環
只是殊不知
這個降息循環
走得相當的緩慢
那大家本來預期
想嚐到的甜頭都沒嚐到
反而就是套住的人
大有人在
那反倒現在又回到
升息的循環
那這個時候
我就想給投資朋友
一個建議
那先提供一個數字
那根據彭博的資訊
其實截至今年的7月底
巴西的實質利率是9.6%
美國只有0.25%
如果你只有一筆錢
你拿去買
巴西政府的公債
你的息收是遠遠超過
美國公債的
但是台灣投資人
都是喜歡買美債
主要就會覺得說
美債安全
穩定
不過其實
美債的價格波動
不見得
比新興市場來得小
這幾年我想
大家都已經體驗過了
但確實
因為剛剛大展哥
提的例子是巴西
一般來說巴西我們
有在投資圈比較久的人
就把它定位是在
新興市場
所以你的意思是說
比起美債
你會認為說
也許可以考慮
放在新興市場來領高息
你透過剛剛的比較
讓大家知道了
因為你說現在看起來
美債的波動度
可能不亞於新興市場債
但是新興市場
可以創造的
息收是更高的
但是尷尬的就是
新興市場這四個字
也是很多人聽到就怕
對投資人定位
真的很尷尬
尤其還是被當成配菜
景氣好的時候
確實還不錯
但是稍微有風吹草動
就要跑
你說的沒錯
其實新興市場債
長期都被大家當成是
戰術性的配置
那我想先跟觀眾朋友分享
現在情況已經不一樣
那大家可以看到
這張圖卡
其實這是
從新興市場債市的
一個資金流向
長年都是
流出的情形
但是從2025年已經
由負轉正
而且2025年
流入新興市場
債市的資金
就有309億美元
那今年到5月底為止
又流入了244億美元
一年多的一個時間
總共流入了553億美元
所以錢已經
開始在回流了
只是台灣投資人多半
都還是不知道
所以其實
從這個資金流向
我們就讓投資人明白了
我們很喜歡說
為什麼觀察
全球資金流向
很重要
因為我們會說有一種錢
叫做聰明錢
聰明錢
他們一定就是眼光會比
大家看得更精準
所以現在看得出來
趨勢很明顯
錢開始回流到新興市場
但是重點還是想要問
就是追求報酬的同時
我們必須要
可以承擔風險
承擔波動
所以新興市場的風險
比較高
這句話是對的嗎
我想其實
新興市場的
本身體質
當然的一個變化
是長年都是在
有不同的經濟循環
有不同的狀況
那隨時要依據當時的
經濟情形去做決定
那這個新興市場債市
但是經過整個循環
我還是想先分享一個
比較長期的
因為比較扭轉
大家的一個印象
其實長期而言
新興市場債的報酬
其實不亞於美債
如果你看這張圖
這個是過去20年來
主要固定收益資產的
報酬表現
如果我們把起始點設為
20年前設為100
那結到今年3月
新興市場公司債
大概是300
這樣數字
就是20年大概3倍
那在複利的效果之下
新興市場強勢貨幣債
大概在293
也是接近300
甚至大家比較陌生
待會會比較多介紹的
新興市場本地債
大概是218
那大家會覺得
最安全的美國公債
反而只有175
甚至全球綜合型的債券是163
那反應在這些數字之下
其實債券市場本身
就有個長期的複利效果
那剛剛提到
這樣子的一個數字
就是新興市場債市
長年期大概就有6到7%
這樣子一個年化報酬率
可是美國公債在這些
升息循環的
一個情況之下
這20年來年化其實只有4%
所以新興市場債券
它是有一定的信用價差
可以有比較高的
利息收入
可以反而去彌補
中間景氣循環
帶來一個波動
所以在這個情況之下
我們覺得
大家對新興市場的印象
其實應該可以去扭轉說
它好像波動比較大
那甚至回到我們看到
比較是基本面的部分
那大家比較少關注
我想這張圖卡
就是可以 跟大家去分享一下
是說
其實新興市場
現在的體質
真的已經是不一樣
我們來看看這邊
有四個指標
GDP的成長
財政赤字
經常帳和金融債的餘額
還有債務佔GDP比重
所以可以看到最右邊
新興市場這一組
經濟成長率
大概都在4%左右
這是持續是在擴張的
財政赤字
都還可以控制到3%到4%
甚至債務佔GDP的比率
現在大概在6成
甚至比很多的成熟國家
都還來得低
確實剛剛大展哥也透過
實質的數據
然後我們常講的
甚至會說績效會說話
讓大家已經看到了
首先新興市場基本面
已經改善了
所以整個經濟結構狀況
是更好的
這我想到個譬喻
就是有點像就是說
我們以前印象中那種
比較容易惹麻煩的
叛逆青少年
現在轉大人了
對不對
因為過去新興市場
就是真的是
債借太多
通膨管不住
動不動就失控
然後匯率
也一下就崩了
但看起來
從剛剛
基本面的四大指標觀察
現在
他轉大人成熟了
沒錯
我覺得 是非常好的一個比喻
那其實很多新興國家
其實就成熟了
他們建立了
一個財政規則
也用制度去限制
整個政府能借多少債
能花多少
那央行也從整個在
通膨目標的部分
也非常嚴格的這樣做控管
設定通膨目標之後
再回到整個設定
調整利率
那貨幣政策的獨立性
也強了很多
那還有一個數字
非常有代表性的
就是符合可以進入性
流動性
透明度標準
可以納到整個主要債券
指數的一個新興國家
2003年只有31個
現在已經到67個國家了
所以市場變寬了
也變深了
OK
那現在
投資人好奇的問題
就是
我們剛剛已經從資金面
然後基本面
還有過往的績效面
看得出來確實它的機會
是存在的
但投資人想知道的是
那在新興債市裡面
有這麼多的國家
錢要往哪裡放
OK
那我覺得
可以從實質利率的
角度來看
簡單的講實質利率
就是名目利率
去減掉通膨
就是真正到你口袋裡的
這個報酬
可以想像如果
你今天存在銀行
利率是20%
好像很多
可是
當地的通膨還超過20%
你根本其實還是負報酬
那我們看這張圖
在整個這張圖的
最左邊那個深藍色
是成熟國家
中間綠色這個群組是
新興市場
那右邊紫色
這個相對上
比較發展沒那麼成熟的
邊境市場
那深色的這個柱狀圖
是呈現現在的實質利率
淺色的柱狀圖是呈現
未來12個月的
一個預估值
那我們看看左邊那一群
瑞典
美國
加拿大
英國
日本
實質利率都貼在零附近
甚至日本和紐西蘭
還是負值
然後再看中間
巴西
土耳其
哥倫比亞
墨西哥
南非
甚至最右邊
剛剛說比較邊緣的
這個新興市場
奈及利亞
烏克蘭
烏茲別克
埃及
喬治亞
哈薩克
這些實質利率都明顯
高出一大段
更重要的是
淺色的柱子
就是預估未來12個月
新興市場跟成熟國家
實質利率的差距
還是會持續維持在高檔
所以說
我們用這個實質利率
來看
確實顯現出來
現在相較於成熟國家
新興市場的實質利率
是高的
而且這也是比較誘人的
那如果我們
用數字轉換的話
就講最早最早
我們提到的巴西好了
巴西現在的實質利率
目前是9.61%
那反觀
美國當然就是
沒有那麼高的
那如果說用100萬元
放在巴西的利率環境
簡單來說算個數學題
光是實質利率
它一年理論上
就有將近9萬6元的空間
對 沒錯
投資在當地國家
真的是有
滿高的殖利率可以享受
那我們都不討論
匯率的影響
理論上就是這樣
那當然對全球的
大型資金來講的話
這就像看到一個
房客也越來越穩定的
黃金店面
這就是為什麼說
2025年開始
有資金流入新興債市
我們現在可以理解了
其實就是吸引力
導致資金回流
就是璇依一直提到的
聰明錢
那如果我們想要
進一步選擇
其實新興市場債
分兩種
那其實一開始
大展哥就有提到了
一個可能就是
我們比較
熟悉的
常聽到的
美元計價的
強勢貨幣債
另外一種是
當地貨幣計價的
本地債
又來了
要怎麼選擇
我覺得現在大家可以把
焦點多關注在本地債
雖然說強勢貨幣債
比較是美元為主
但是本地債現在的
投資機會其實也開始
都在上升
因為新興國家的
基本面都轉好
那它的匯率也都有
一定的一個支撐
而且甚至都在升息的
一個趨勢裡面
那我們這邊就用
三個國家來做說明
第一個是巴西
那這張圖卡
藍線是巴西幣
對美元的匯率
往下代表升值
然後淺綠線
是巴西本地
10年期公債殖利率的
一個水準
那這張圖我們可以看到
從2024年的12月
巴西幣一度貶到
1美元可以換
6元的巴西幣
那時候大家是
都在說巴西完蛋了
可是到今年7月
大概一年半的時間
可以看到
巴西幣已經升值到
1美元只能換到
5元的巴西幣
其實用數學來換算
這個匯率就已經
升值快2成
那更何況還有
殖利率是14%
所以你又拿殖利率
又拿匯率
這是一個滿高的數字
所以不但是賺到了匯率
那甚至也還是收到了
投資人很滿意的
這樣的債息
那巴西是大家比較
廣為人知
還有沒有其他的國家例子
也可以跟觀眾朋友分享
我想新興市場的國家
真的是很多
那我剛剛舉巴西
可能大家會比較
耳熟能詳
好像就是一個
新興市場的代名詞
那我再舉一個例子
馬來西亞
我們鄰近亞洲的馬來西亞
其實馬來西亞也算是
新興國家那我想
雖然是新興市場
但是它的財政是
相對的穩定
所以它10年期的一個
公債殖利率只有
3.7%左右
那5年來
它的公債殖利率都在
3%到4.6%
都比美債還來得低
可是
它的整個
馬來西亞貨幣
2024年的4月
最貶到
1美元兌換4.78元的馬來西亞幣
升到今年7月份
已經升到4元
所以
升值大概有17%
那所以很明顯
它就是賺的就是
這個匯差
你看它升值幅度
是有17%
所以不同的新興國家的投資
邏輯原則都是不同的
像馬來西亞
你會覺得說
它的利率水準
你說新興國家
也沒有那麼高
可是這幾年你還是
可以賺到匯差的部分
那既然我們知道
巴西
馬來西亞
那有沒有光譜的
另外一端
就是你講這種
超級極端的
它的殖利率可能
聽起來超級高
但它的匯率波動
可能也很刺激的
那我可以舉個例子
我講奈及利亞
璇依你應該沒去過
但我知道在非洲
就是地圖上有看過
它當地的殖利率
有到17到20%
是真的很高息
奈及利亞貨幣從2024年
貶到最低的
一個數字
到今年7月
這個波段已經回升
大概24%
所以非常明顯
它就是一個殖利率
跟匯率都是高波動的
一個市場
這是不是邊境市場的特性
對不對
所以其實剛剛
大展哥分享了
3個市場
讓大家去理解
那我一路聽下來的
重點就是
這樣的本地貨幣債的
報酬方式其實是
有3塊
第一個當然就是
殖利率本身
也就是所謂的這個
債券的票息
那第二個就是
殖利率下降帶來的
價差
另外還有
匯兌收益
像我可能都已經
有點投資經驗了
我都還是覺得說
天啊太複雜了
而且有一些國家
它地理位置在哪邊
我們都不太確定
然後基本面也很難了解
更不用說去判斷
它的財政狀況
就算現在聽起來很心動
一般人要如何介入
是的
我想這就是要交給專家
只要你懂得把事情
交給有能力的人去做
像今天就是想跟大家
分享一個專家
就是威廉博萊
而且我知道這樣的專家
其實就是我們是操作
算是主動基金對不對
我們其實不是被動的
追蹤指數
而是
這樣的一個專家
他操作叫做主動基金
在經理人
就不會只買進
像剛剛那樣子
奈及利亞
就是高風險高波動的債券
而是會搭配的
因為其實大家
投資債券是想要領息
也希望可以降低
整個投組的波動
所以說
我覺得透過這樣的專家
優點應該就是在
追求收益的同時
也可以來幫大家
降低波動
因此不會犧牲太多的總報酬
可是也想要請大展哥
好好跟大家來介紹一下
這個專家
威廉博萊
它的厲害之處
還有它的背景
這威廉博萊的總部
是在美國的一個芝加哥
那公司從創立到今
大概91年的一個時間
非常久
它的定位很清楚
主要是走的是
精品的一個路線
不是全產品線
那新興市場債
這個領域就是它的強項
那大家要知道說
追蹤全球市場的動態
不僅是需要整宏觀的視野
那具體上還需要
更強大的一個交易平台
以及深入當地市場的
研究能力
那各位想像
一組人
分佈在巴西
菲律賓
南非
跨時區的
盯著這些市場
還有主權債
當地利率
貨幣
企業信用債等
各種領域的一個專家
這不只是
研究能力的問題
還有規模的問題
所以我想
會跟投資人去分享是說
資訊不對稱這件事情
你不用自己扛
這邊有很多
經理人的這個專業
你是可以
有效降低你的風險
那台灣的這個投資人
要透過威廉博萊
來投資新興市場
有什麼樣的工具
你覺得很適合
在這個時間點
投資人可以介入
我們總代理
威廉博萊的一個基金
現在在台灣總共有4檔
那除了一些
股票型基金以外
在新興市場的
債券的部分
我們除了去年引進了
這個以美元計價的
新興市場非投資等級債券基金
那今年就特別
想跟大家推薦的就是
威廉博萊新興市場本地貨幣債券基金
所以等於就是
有點像是把這個
新興市場債的產品線
給補齊了
不論是美元計價
或是本地的貨幣計價的
這樣的新興市場基金
其實都有辦法
可以讓大家來參與
本來美元計價那一檔
賺的是債券本身
那這一檔
是再加上當地貨幣
跟當地利率
讓報酬的來源更加完整
而且這檔很特別是說
它不像很多產品
單純是用地區來分配
各國的一個曝險程度
什麼意思
一般我們看債券
不就是用
地區來劃分嗎
請看這張圖
在右邊紫色的部分
是市場上一般的分法
我們照地區分組
也是拉美一組
亞洲一組
歐非中東一組
然後再決定
說我每個區域
要配多少一個投資比
那再看看
拉美那一組裡面
其實有
同時有阿根廷
智利
墨西哥
那阿根廷是什麼體質
它常常在違約
智利又是什麼體質
其實它是
Single A的一個國家
所以
所以阿根廷是容易違約
其實反而是
比較不好的下面的
但是智利
基本上它是優質的債券
是的
所以這兩個國家的
一個體質風險
是天差地遠
如果把它放在
同一個框框裡面
這樣子去做分配
其實就會失真
那同樣是
在歐非中東那一組
你看到南非
波蘭跟烏克蘭
那烏克蘭跟波蘭
又是不一樣的一個風險
所以真的不能
單純用地區來劃分
那威廉博萊他們
劃分的做法是什麼
這邊就看到
這個圖卡上左邊這
藍色這一塊
就是威廉博萊它
不是用地區法劃分
它是用Beta的屬性
那白話來講就是說
國家對市場的波動
有多敏感
那我們看高Beta的部分
當中就是有阿根廷
烏克蘭
埃及
這些波動大
或剛剛提到的奈及利亞
波動大
但相對機會也大的
那中Beta池放的是巴西
墨西哥
南非
那在低Beta
這個這一組
是放的是智利
波蘭跟菲律賓
體質相對比較穩健
那這樣子的做法的好處
就是第一
它風險預算分配
更有效率
它不會一不小心
就把風險集中在
同樣一個體質的國家
第二
如果做相對價值評估的時候
會可以是同等級的
去做比較
判斷也比較精準
第三
如果市場環境變了
你真的要整個調整
投資組合的Beta的曝險程度
也可以比較快速的做調整
所以確實聽起來
是很聰明的分類方式
而且還兼顧到了就是
投資人
對於這個風險程度
還有整個投資組合的
Beta值的來控制
那配置比例的話
又是多少
那看這張表
這檔基金
在風險預算的
配置的架構
那在高Beta這個部分
也就是風險最高
最刺激的部分
單一國家的
主動曝險程度
也只能佔
大概0.25%到0.75%
就看整個投資團隊的
研究的一個信心度多高
最多也就是放到1.5%
那反過來看
低波動這個群組
體質比較穩的這部分
標準狀況是
可以看到放到0.75%
到1.5%
在高強度的信心
可以就放到2.5%
這樣子的一個跟
指標上的差距
所以這個主動積極的程度
跟你今天曝險的一個程度
都可以動態去做調整
其實最大優點
就是因為它是一個
主動基金
是由這個經理人
還有整個團隊
會去調配
然後根據
每一個國家的基本面
還有Beta值的狀況
然後以及
剛剛這個限定的
限制範圍之內
讓整個投組的狀態
是可以有機會
創造總報酬
在可控的範圍之內
是的
非常謝謝大展哥
今天的分享
讓我們今天真的知道了
現在新興市場的體質
已經改變了
無論是它的經濟成長
財政紀律
還有整個通膨的管理
都跟過去不一樣了
像璇依剛剛說的
過去的叛逆青少年
現在轉大人了
所以
不但是基本面的改善
實質利率
透過數字圖表
剛剛都發現了
明顯是高於成熟國家的
狀況之下
如果說你
對於這樣的債券投資
或是這樣的
債券主動基金
尤其是在
新興市場的部分
你好奇的話
大家可以多加來留意
新興市場債市的投資機會
Smart投資教室
我們下回再見
掰掰